all right here comes head three two one
action
they created this whole
crazy epic world this season everyone is
changing and evolving it's just really
exciting i think people will be blown
away when they see what season two looks
like
boom
love my job
season two it's amazing what we've
pulled off it's not an easy thing to
create these
huge epic worlds these civilizations
these kingdoms let us not wait till they
knock down our gates
i say we open it right now
and protect what is ours and all costs
for season two we wanted to come down
off the mountains and see what life was
like in what used to be the cities
leaving season one and coming into a
city and seeing its decay after 600
years it's a whole different look you
know he's crawling back into hell
we are moving along geographically and
we come to places that would be cities
in the aftermath all those hundreds of
years in the future
how cold is the jet
negative 20.
[Laughter]
i like the cold i don't know i always
end up in the cold or in water
we took that destroyed city aesthetic
and really ran with it
just the expanse of it's pretty
spectacular the main street where we've
turned cars on their end and stacked
them to be the wall
and then we used quite literally a bus
as the gate
it was quite a sight actually
we always want to kind of make scope and
scale and the hern allowed that because
of the geography of of this coal-fired
plant that's just massive
this is one of the coolest sets i've
ever been out of my life
look over there
it's amazing
i've never been in a building that big
there's some shots in there that are
just like unbelievable
a lot of the things we build are
beautiful but there's also a lot of
logic built into it
we have a full crew of artists who build
everything for the show in-house which
is really unique for television
i just love that we can put things in
there that we know from our times and
they've become something else i think
that's brilliant it forces you to think
outside the box and use your other
senses for fabrics by touch it's the
texture and then also does it make sound
my queen
[Music]
this is basically me being a
six-year-old boy dream come true best
best outfit ever you're gonna be a
samurai
[Music]
jason would be the quintessential
warrior in all factions
love for japanese culture happened to
coincide with jason's love for japanese
culture
and he always wanted to have this kind
of influence and so i thought hey let's
let's do samurai
my whole life i wanted to play somewhere
i love you jimbo and seven samurai and
so i always wanted to play a character
like that
when you see him emerge in that along
with the robes the kimono and the hakama
he looks
powerful
i had all these made for me
for that
jason loves his weapons
yeah
i had a dream of different things i
wanted to make peace out the antlers
that i wanted picked out the style of
knife that i wanted
finally it's here
look at that
the swords were made in hawaii the rest
of them pretty much in texas that is
perfect
everything from the weapons to the
costume department to the sets
department everyone really wants to
elevate the season
there's too many of them advanced
in the world of sea you can be the queen
you can be a leader of a tribe
you can be a warrior
each individual is treated as an equal
in our show
look at this this is why i love movies
all these beautiful people
that make it possible i get to travel
the world and meet all types of artists
that get to build worlds like this we
all come together to make something that
hopefully changes your perspective and
uh
and be compassionate to other people's
lives
i love it
the level of ambition on this show is
through the roof
this whole season has been
incredible
i am a father
i am a husband
i am your friend
i
and i'm fighting for your freedom until
the day that i die
you